Theo bào cao cầu bố nguyễn 5 tháng 20 của cuộc thống K, một tại chính,
thu nhập bình quân của người la động sau tháng đầu năm 2019 đã tám về ba sự động một tháng,
tăng bày chăm sóm với nghìn động, tương ứng mười về một phân chăm sóm với cuộc kỳ năm 2020.
Trong đó, thu nhập bình quân của la động năm là chính về ba sự động một tháng,
la động nữ là bày về một sự động.
thu nhập bình quân của la động ở khu vực thành thị là mười sự động một tháng,
khu vực nông thu nhập bày hay sự động một tháng.
Tỳ lệ tất nghiệp trong độ tuổi là động sau tháng đầu năm 2019 là 2,5,
giảng khu vực không năm 2019 sợ với cuộc kỳ năm trước, trong đó khu vực thành thị là 2,5 mươi phần chăm,
khu vực nông thu là 2,5 mươi phần chăm.
Tỳ lệ tất nghiệp của tháng nghiên, tương mười năm 2019,
sau tháng đầu năm 2019 là 3,5 mươi phần chăm,
giảng tỳ lệ tất nghiệp của tháng nghiênu khu vực thành thị là mười phần sau 1,5 mươi phần chăm.
Cùng với đó, tỳ lệ lệ tất ổng hôm sự giụ hết tìm năng trong sâu tháng đầu năm 2018,
giảng khu vực vụ nỉnh phần chăm sợ với cuộc kỳ năm 2019.